[Music]
in all-or-nothing news Oh submitted by
David marry me sure what's wrong with
you they like they like a high school
passed a rule that everyone makes the
cheerleading squad or no one does
because everybody needs to be in class
[ __ ] hate that they're just setting
up these kids for failure that this
shit's terrible because when I become a
parent I'm gonna have to go to the ship
and watch terrible cheerleaders [ __ ]
toss people and fall and break their
[ __ ] legs because everybody's
included what do you throw some women
don't catch nothing I remember junior
high high school that there was fat
cheerleaders ugly other leaders whatever
but they do try it out and they worked
and they got the they got the rolls they
could still move yeah that one still
could do backflips made the spot they
got the spot yeah and I think me as a
kid like trying to get back into that
mindset like I wanted to know I made it
because I was good at something like
like I feel like a piece of [ __ ] like
you know when they would give you like
the pity awards and stuff yeah everyone
gets I'm like I don't want to get this
person sucks like what am I getting this
thing than they are
that was me though yeah it's like you
want to feel something special and
everybody everybody wins something like
just because somebody's not a
cheerleader somebody else you know that
person isn't good at art you know what
I'm saying to me once earlier that could
draw you know like everybody's good at
zero drawing cheerleaders out there
successful stand-up comedian right yeah
somebody who's like done one stand up
they're like we should do a show
together that person's on cocaine
usually if they come up like yeah I
don't believe in this like skill
equality I think I thought humans should
be equal but like this let's everyone
can make it in the same team like
everyone everyone should have an equal
chance everyone should be able to be to
try out for those cheering team like
there should never be a reason why they
do it do it but then now after that
point it's like are they good enough to
be can't have 200 first-place medals
then like in the workplace like
someone's gonna get a promotion your
neck why did I get a good sorry why
don't I get a promotion it's like well
cuz this is my way of having all
cheerleaders yeah you know what don't
you have the Olympics anymore [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
right right we should what's the point
of finding out who's the best yeah it's
just mail everybody a medal yeah I mean
who's gonna who's gonna be in the
football team if the whole class is
cheerleaders alright or the whole class
of the football team yeah takes place in
New Jersey and apparently after tryouts
there were some cuts have tryouts one
parents one complain that their child
was not allowed on the team and so the
athletic director changed the entire
policy so it's the athletic directors
fault that parent is doing such a
disservice to their child no scared of a
lawsuit yeah oh they do know that that
girl is gonna go into the [ __ ]
cheerleading squad and they're gonna
spit on her rip her head out make fun of
her they don't do all [ __ ] for a hair
out
I don't know isn't that what they do at
school so I'm gonna play a clip of one
of the cheerleaders yes and quit huh a
very bad school I like schools with a
little bit of bullying though I like a
little bit bullying prepares for the
real - I mean there's a pecking order
for sure like even amongst freakin
animals there's the pecking order it's
like you'd stay in your lane like you're
good or you're bad or like you're
stronger you're weak like yeah and your
struggle your journey is what makes you
even mate and means anything anything
worthwhile having it gives you some type
of struggle yeah I think like even like
the best comedians have like the most
fun yeah it's like the most interesting
[ __ ] stories dude like all those all
the comedians that I that I [ __ ] love
they always have like weird perspective
because of something that they went
through selling hams and [ __ ] czars
getting molested you can't even tell a
joke if you were molested
you were molested probably yeah so
easier there by your sister
we got a friendship I mean so many kids
once I'm living in our house you had it
somebody yeah somebody touch somebody I
couldn't turn on the light switch
without hitting somebody's kid you know
it was just so many kids at the house
hey you wanna be my friend which is the
[ __ ] mouth feel well yeah start above
the head connect a few it straight to
the but I know
gosh bro to question we call that family
to Christian is very to Christian they
don't call it but buddies for no reason
that is very Christian I'm still a
virgin I got [ __ ] the ass wow there's
like some weird like Christian people
like like just if the church stories are
the most insane yeah like how they view
like your virginity is was the funniest
thing to me it's like if I got [ __ ] in
the ass I'm still a virgin
I had a church leader right this is like
after I left the church and you know we
all went our separate ways God was like
hey remember in uh when we were at
church and you told us all that you were
a [ __ ] virgin right and she goes yeah
what's the virgin I was like you weren't
a [ __ ] virgin I know who you [ __ ]
right it was our friend right and she
goes but he didn't come inside me are
you a [ __ ] adult like what did you
say he comes on my face neighbor Jim
what are these rules come from like who
taught you these not at the Bible yeah
you know it means something like
somebody teach me these rules yeah like
[ __ ] the a from Stila Bridget do you
look like a guinea pig at us realize it
a little bit at all but dude look at
look one up and used to say beautiful
you like I think for the last minute he
didn't hear a single word you said yes
you're making eye contact he's like what
does he look like you sell you why do I
have an affinity toward this yeah bro
you really really do man I think it's
the eyes
hairless guinea pigs I mean this one off
obviously works at a garden but it's
like a little bit guy that looks like a
mouse yeah you got a look yeah so I
wanted to show you a video clip of one
of the cheerleaders crying telling the
principal and like the whole school
board why this rule sucks cool here we
go
anyone who wants to cheer can be on the
squad
this rule is being met with mixed
reaction and very strong emotions from
students on the squad who do not agree
[Music]
anyone can be out the squad now so why
practice and they're standing by the
decision you know what also sucks too
though is that there's probably hella
other issues that it could be talking
about because the board only gets
together like once a week and then now
they have to waste that meeting on
something stupid like I know they could
have been talking about more important
[ __ ] like what kind of sides should they
start having for lunch like should they
change the mac and cheese with collard
greens what should they do
mmm the missing kimchi oh yeah no
diversity right that I like it the
principal was threatening to just
disband the whole squad altogether so
then that's when like the parents kind
of backed off a little bit cause we
still want the squad so then now they're
standing by Asians have to be the
[ __ ] one white guess that says that
[ __ ] I should over here you have a girl
crying she lost her whole dreams you
don't think her dad has a gun who knows
what she's gonna do now you know I'm
saying like you just make this where it
doesn't mean anything to anybody
yeah yeah I wouldn't even want to be the
girl known to be the one that cried that
I didn't make the cut I'm saying she's
gonna get her face ripped off that's
probably what's her name maybe Bridget
Tiffany you forgot that Tiffany is in
every little girl cheerleader name that
is true there's a lot of children you
know we had a girl named TIFF in our
town but it was um and I thought I was
trough for Tiffany but it was short for
it was short for nothing it was like I
asked her mom one time I was like for
Tiffany she's like no it's for like when
you get in an argument with somebody
yeah and I was like that says she just
argues with everybody in town and no I
don't know this is what her mom named
her after which is just so bizarre
yeah TIFF and I was it go for Tiffany
and her mom's like no for when like a
little argument yeah that's how she was
made baby baby that's what it was that's
a good thought and for 404 an and
something no no quiet for annoying
[Laughter]
annoying annoying that's what all these
new kids are gonna be named it's gonna
be that's exactly what its gonna be like
all these new kids names I mean y'all
have children's do you see this at your
school if I go to if I like take if I go
on a school tour and I find out that
everybody can get into everything I'm
leaving that school yeah I would pull
them out cuz I want my kid to work his
ass off so everyone gets a check [ __ ]
they have like what the [ __ ] is this
everyone's [ __ ] participating in [ __ ]
what is like planet I'm Tigers in school
every school is this ridiculous home
school baby school is your prep you prep
care for for jobs right and there are
Norton there are no corporations that do
that so there has to be some some
schools right like a corporation you
like everybody can work here even if you
don't have the skills yeah the
corporation is like if you don't [ __ ]
make money if you can't do it you're out
yeah imagine the medical field could be
a doctor your doctor your doctor [ __ ]
that you're a surgeon
you could be a surgeon we got to shake
hands hands
you should be an eye surgeon Michael J
Fox is a heart surgeon issue
[Music]